Welcome.
We're with the Ismaili dialogue, the master and the disciple, and the line every Muslim recites in difficulty.
There is no power and no strength except through Allah read tonight as the confession of an entire chain of intermediaries.
There is no power and no strength except through Allah means there is no imam and no gateway except through Allah.
The entire chain is itself dependent at every link.
It's such an incredibly profound shift in perspective, because if you're listening to us, you have almost certainly heard this formula.
Oh, absolutely.
It's just totally woven into the everyday fabric of life, you know, recited in moments of deep distress or, well, just quiet reliance.
But the source text here asks us to pause.
Yes, it asks us to examine its classical Ismaili reading, to treat it not just as a comforting phrase, but as a map.
A structural map, exactly.
And we actually have a tradition recorded from the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family, that calls this very formula a treasure from the treasures of paradise.
A treasure, yes.
And because it is a treasure, it demands A long-form exploration of its inner architecture.
That is our mission here.
Okay, let's unpack this.
Well, to really understand the inner dimension the author is pointing toward, we have to start with the literal readings.
Right.
What happens when you rely entirely on the common interpretations?
Exactly.
Yeah.
So in the dialogue, the disciple is asked to define the two key Arabic terms, hall and quawa.
And what does he say for the first one?
So for the first term, hall,
He offers the standard interpretation.
He says it means the year.
A year?
How does he arrive at a year from a divine formula?
Well, he bases it entirely on a literal reading of a Quranic reference.
There's a verse regarding mothers suckling their children for two complete halls.
I see.
So the word is used there to denote that specific passage of time.
Yeah, exactly.
And then for the second term, quawa, the disciple says it means mules.
Wait, mules.
I know, it sounds strange.
How do you get from a word that generally means strength or power to pack animals?
It comes from folklore, basically.
Historical commentary.
He cites the story of Korun or Kora.
The story of his massive wealth.
Exactly.
The tradition says
had wealth so massive that just the keys to his treasures were too heavy to lift.
They required a band of strong men to carry them.
And that band of strong men translates to mules.
Yeah, and the comment telling the disciple relies on that raw strength was said to mean 40 men, and the capacity required was said to mean 40 mules.
So we just let that stand for a breath.
It's quite a leap.
Because the author is trying to show you what happens when you strip a phrase of its spiritual framework.
You take a formula that is a treasure from the treasures of.
A lion carried into battle.
Yes, recited in severe human difficulty.
And if you strictly follow those literal definitions, the translation you're left with is there is no year and no mule except through Allah.
It's completely absurd.
It collapses under its own weight.
It offers no comfort, no theology.
No real meaning at all.
It is entirely absurd.
And that absurdity is the author's entire point.
I don't buy that yet calling meals absurd is fine, but reading Hall as the imam
Looks like substituting 1 vocabulary for another.
Aren't you just swapping out words to make it fit?
It looks that way on the surface, I admit, but it is not a mere substitution.
How is it any less arbitrary, though, if we're just crossing out words in a dictionary?
Because to understand the text, you have to grasp the underlying principle the scholar is operating from.
No word of truth lacks a source in the inner dimension.
And no falsehood exists that didn't once have a real meaning before being turned away and made absurd.
So the argument is that the original vocabulary isn't the problem.
Not at all.
The problem is that the entire conceptual architecture behind the words has been forgotten.
The words became hollow shells.
Precisely.
And people filled those shells with things like years and mules because they lost the keys to the inner dimension.
So how do we recover that architecture?
The text instructs us to look at the numeric and linguistic signatures.
The first term relates linguistically to the Arabic concept of Tawril.
Which means conversion.
Yes, conversion.
So this points directly to the Imam, the one who convuls divine speech.
Let's pause there.
Why is conversion so central?
What is being converted?
Divine speech is pure spirit.
The words of wisdom human beings hear are the body and form.
The Imam is the converter between them.
Oh, I see.
Let's linger on that for a second.
Because if we think about pure spirit, it is entirely formless.
It is immense.
It's overwhelming, yeah.
You cannot grasp a spirit without a body.
If the creator's speech remained in its pure spiritual state.
Humanity would have absolutely no capacity to receive it.
Or understand it, let alone act upon it.
Exactly.
You cannot hear divine speech without it taking the physical form of human words.
Bound by grammar, sound, context, the imam provides that vital conversion.
Translating the pure spiritual intent into a form human intellects can survive encountering.
Yes.
But the model doesn't stop there.
The second term relates to physical capability, to execution and strength.
So if the first figure is the converter, the strategist, then the next rank in the hierarchy must be the strength that carries it.
Correct.
The next rank is the gateway, the one who bears and disseminates it.
The gateway must be the strength that bears these mighty words into the community.
That is exactly the mechanism.
The gateway takes the cure, concentrated wisdom, what the text calls the mujmal.
In a condensed form.
Right.
They take that condensed form and distribute it downward.
Because it's still too dense for the general public.
Exactly.
The gateway disseminates it to the Duat in a highly detailed, accessible form.
And those callers are the ones who interact directly with the community.
Yes.
It is the structure of a general giving orders to captains who then pass them on to soldiers.
That makes perfect sense.
I mean, think about how a military actually operates.
A general doesn't walk down to the battlefield and hand a raw 50-page strategic vision to a private.
It would be totally useless in the heat of action.
The general gives the condensed orders to the captains, and the captains break it down into actionable steps for the soldiers.
According to the dialogue, this is how spiritual truth travels.
Every rank receives the speech in the precise form its level can bear.
And passes it to the next rank in the form that lower rank can bear.
There is no power and no strength except through Allah means there is no imam and no gateway except through Allah.
The entire chain is itself dependent at every link.
Isn't this just replacing a literal frame with an esoteric one?
How is this different from a secret code where X just means Y?
It's a fair question.
I mean, if the first term just equals the imam
and the second just equals the gateway.
Have we just created a new exclusive dictionary?
The text argues it is fundamentally different from a Slack code because it functions across multiple realities and eras.
It is a living architecture.
Okay, how so?
The scholar provides A two-context refinement.
Strategy is a function of the mind and execution is a physical capability.
Strategy and execution.
Yes.
Let's look at the first context.
The era of a new revelation.
The strategy is provided by the Natik.
So in that specific era, the speaker prophet transforms the divine speech to provide the overarching strategy.
They established a law.
And the execution of that law, the actual implementation in the physical world.
That is carried out by the WASI.
I see.
The executor acts as the strength that bears that strategy into the world.
That is context one, but watch how the exact same architecture remains intact in context two.
The era of ongoing spiritual authority.
Yes, after the law is established.
In this context, the overarching strategy is devised by the imam.
And the execution, the practical dissemination to the believers, is carried out by the bab.
And the hujjah acts as that executing strength on an even broader scale.
The proof.
It makes sense.
The higher rank provides the strategy and the conversion.
The lower rank executes it.
And neither has the capacity to do either except as the Creator enables them.
It's not a code.
It's a description of how gravity works in the spiritual universe.
What's fascinating here is how the text applies this.
It argues that this hidden hierarchy isn't just buried in our daily prayers.
Where does it take us next?
It moves to prophetic history itself.
The dialogue specifically points us to the chapter on Joseph, verse 4.
Yes.
Joseph speaks to his father about a vision he had of the night sky.
He says, indeed I have seen 11 stars and the sun and the moon prostrating to me.
We have 3 distinct celestial bodies there.
The sun, the moon, and 11 stars.
That sounds like wordplay, 12 months, 12 chiefs.
What stops me reading any 12 into the chain?
Couldn't the brothers just be a biological family?
It's tempting to read it that way.
If a child dreams of his family bowing to him and he has 11 brothers, isn't it just a literal dream about sibling rivalry?
If you stop at the biological family, the text argues you completely miss the doctrinal precision of the narrative.
Where does the text correct that?
The scholar points us further down the page to verse 8 of that same chapter.
The brothers express deep jealousy over their father's affection for Joseph.
But the Ismaili reading insists these 12 brothers
were Isaac's cabinet.
Exactly.
They were not merely biological siblings having a petty swabble.
They were a formalized spiritual council, his new Kaaba.
So they were an official council, the 12 chiefs.
Yes.
When you apply the architectural key we just discussed, the symbols align perfectly.
The sun in the dream is Isaac.
The source of the strategic light.
The moon, which reflects the light of the sun, is Joseph's own gateway.
And the 11 stars are the remaining 11 members of the chiefs.
Precisely.
I concede the point.
When you frame it as a cabinet, the numbers aren't decoration.
They are deliberate structural signs of the chosen ranks.
The literal reading turns a profound cosmic architecture into something almost soap opera-like.
A petty family quarrel.
But when you understand the signs, you see the chain.
Which brings us to the second great vision in that chapter.
The king's dream.
Yes.
This is the famous sequence where the Egyptian king dreams of 7 fat cows being eaten by 7 lean ones.
And 7 green ears of wheat growing alongside 7 dry ears.
To the people of Egypt, the outer dimension of this vision is just a mirage.
It's interpreted purely as a warning of an agricultural famine.
But the inner dimension reveals the exact same chain of intermediaries using the language of sustenance.
So let's break that down.
The fat cows.
The 7 heavenly intermediaries.
And they are fat and healthy because they are positioned directly between the creator and the earthly realm, feasting on divine proximity.
Yes.
And the seven lean cows are the seven speaker prophets.
Now, why lean?
The text suggests they are lean because they are completely hungry for the revelation that comes to them from above.
Starving for divine speech.
That is a brilliant metaphor.
It really changes how you view a prophet.
They aren't just empty vessels.
They are characterized by an intense, consuming hunger for the truth
devouring the fat ones to gain that heavenly sustenance.
Then the dialogue turns to the agriculture in the dream.
The 7 green ears of wheat are the seven intermediaries between the creator and the executor.
They are green and fresh because they're connected to the source.
And the seven dry ears.
The 7 executors themselves.
They would dry up completely without the sustenance flowing to them from above.
The dry ears represent the earthly administration.
It has no inherent life of its own unless it is actively fed by the green ears.
An agricultural famine in the physical world
is actually a map of how spiritual starvation is prevented in the inner world.
These symbols are like a seed grown into seven ears of grain from whose seed have come seven imams.
The seed contains the entirety of the structure within its shell.
It is the same hermeneutic, the same architecture, the same creator giving the exact same shape to his messages in every register of reality.
It gives you a key to read absolutely everything differently.
A boy's dream of luminaries is the chain of intermediaries.
The king's nightmare about cattle is the chain of intermediaries.
It's all connected.
There is no power and no strength except through Allah means there is no imam and no gateway except through Allah.
The entire chain is itself dependent at every link.
If you're listening to this and reflecting on the sources we've explored,
Which line do you recite without hearing that has been confessing a whole chain to you?
And which piece of that chain will you sit with this week?
We have completely unpacked the inner meaning of this formula and these ancient dreams.
But I want to leave you with a final thought to mull over.
What is that?
If the inner architecture is everything, if the years, the mules, the stars, and the cows are all just metaphors pointing to a hidden spiritual hierarchy, what then of the outer?
That is the big question.
What happens to the physical acts of prayer, of fasting, and of the law you've been observing all your life?
Does discovering the inner truth dissolve the need for the outer practice, or does it make the physical actions infinitely heavier?
That is the tension this text leaves us with.